yeah welcome to this video when playing
only two logo from Spain it's a tues
inion well let's play as image
yeah their various moves move orders
nitey t2 is one of them should be three
Bishop g5 also and this er now gets into
modern benoni structures I have played a
very early nigeria which often
encourages h5 but now after h5 i can
castle age 49 h one's own age five is
not not so much of a problem or
interesting queen a five
you
maybe he's some intending to place you
for not sure yeah I wouldn't mind to
exchange the bishops uh-huh okay if I
play King edge one now he has got H form
and my knight doesn't have a square so i
probably need to drop the bishop back
hmm yeah interesting
why to f6 g7 looks far more natural to
me because I think 95 for t5 it somehow
looks vulnerable on f6 okay I guess now
it's time to push pawns and the samish
it happens that you play f3 f4 later and
get to a position which really am gap it
is more reminiscent of a for porn so
check and you five next if he takes I go
f5 the typical maneuver
yeah to be honest I always some have
problems to understand those positions
Black is some in general and those
benoni structured blacker is supposed to
be alright but I never really understood
how this is correctly playtime I always
had check the I was always under the
impression that why does it's much
easier to play I always thought all
right isn't this great for white but
sometimes I should play a really strong
player he will show that that there are
chances for black no doubt okay so i
have from lots of pieces pointing
towards the kingside the look on h5 is a
particularly aggressively placed
particularly aggressive yeah well don't
mind the the grammar it's it's active
dangerous i hope but how to continue I'd
like to go for 95 when Bishop c4 yeah
Bishop c4
so I'm threatening Bishop f7 now and 95
is a further way to to improve this
looks like a super dangerous attacker I
have a hard time to believe that this
should be okay for black
yeah I'm taking with all my pieces or
close to that so take it now or is there
some battles even check probably not
check and now just look aged six
probably
mm-hmm just to just take you on c5 how
to how to go about that now maybe this
chick
yeah it's not bad
I didn't look at the smooth hmm
ivory stupid
really really awful just look g6 was a
complete lemon maybe the position is so
good that it doesn't matter so much k if
this winds winds f6 but this is less
than certainly not not the the the
optimal outcome
check
check yeah this is giving away even more
black resigns yeah I still rock g6 was a
complete lemon yeah this is certainly
win this position clade b 5 check check
rooks his happiness the best move ok
this still wins but she's excited so but
you cannot spoil it but it's still plus
9 surprising maybe and not surprisingly
i mean it's clear that like it's on the
ropes deserve also just 20 is somewhere
around here it went terribly wrong check
check you said this is probably still
alright but here maybe there are some
other other ways to go this is bishop f6
is really this is real bad this is just
running into into my plane and this I
don't know it's it's at least very
dangerous the computer is not not
convinced but I really don't mind I
really think that the comp
underestimates the Taking Chances Jackie
get this already a convinces the engine
giving white as flat-out wind even now
it's it's just it just too dangerous I
have all the pieces on on it and here i
also can take on on c5 is also strong
yeah thanks for watching